pour une femme, d'être dans la musique,
et d'être si présente dans les médias.
Très vite, donc, j'ai commencé à être attaquée dans mes propres concerts.
Je me souviens un des concerts, j'étais sur scène.
Je me penche vers le public
et la dernière chose que je vois, c'est la figure d'un jeune marron,
et tout ce que je sais, c'est qu'un produit chimique est lancé dans mes yeux.
Et je me souviens que je ne voyais plus rien et mes yeux pleuraient,
mais je continuais à chanter.
On m'a craché au visage dans les rues d'Oslo, cette fois-là, un marron.
Ils ont même tenté, une fois, de me kidnapper.
Les menaces de mort étaient incessantes.
Je me souviens qu'un barbu plus âgé m'a arrêtée, une fois, dans la rue
en disant : « Je vous hais vraiment parce que vous faites penser à nos filles
qu'elles peuvent faire tout ce qu'elles veulent. »
Un gars plus jeune m'a averti de surveiller mes arrières, en disant :
« La musique est non-islamique et le travail des putains.
Si vous continuez, vous allez être violée, et votre estomac va être tranché
afin que vous ne puissiez pas engendrer une autre putain comme vous. »
De nouveau, j'étais si désorientée ! Je ne comprenais pas ce qui se passait.
Mes marrons maintenant, commençaient à me traiter de cette façon.
Comment cela se faisait-il ?
Au lieu de rapprocher les mondes, les deux mondes,
c'était comme si je tombais entre mes deux mondes.
Je suppose que le crachat était pour moi, comme la kryptonite.
Dès l'âge de 17 ans,
les menaces de mort étaient continues et le harcèlement constant.
C'est devenu si grave qu'un jour, ma mère m'a fait asseoir et a dit :
« Nous ne pouvons plus te protéger, assurer ta sécurité.
Il va falloir que tu partes. »
J'ai acheté un aller simple pour Londres. J'ai fait ma valise et je suis partie.
Ma plus grande peine, à ce moment, c'est que personne n'a rien dit.
Mon départ de la Norvège a été très médiatisé.
Mes marrons... Mes blancs... Personne n'a rien dit.
Personne n'a dit : « Attends ! Ce n'est pas juste ! »
« Supportez, protégez cette fille car c'est une des nôtres ! »
Personne n'a dit ça.
Je me sentais plutôt comme, vous savez, à l'aéroport,
sur le carrousel des bagages, vous avez ces valises qui tournent et tournent,
et il y a toujours cette unique valise, à la fin,
celle que personne ne veut, celle que personne ne vient réclamer.
Je me sentais comme ça.
Je ne me suis jamais sentie aussi seule, ni aussi perdue !
Donc, après mon arrivée à Londres,
j'ai finalement repris ma carrière musicale.
Un nouveau lieu, mais, malheureusement, la même vieille histoire.
Je me souviens d'un message disant que j'allais être tuée
et que des rivières de sang allaient se mettre à couler,
et que j'allai être violée plusieurs fois avant de mourir.
À ce point, je dois dire que je commençais à avoir l'habitude de tels messages.
Mais ce qui était différent,
c'était que maintenant, ils commençaient à menacer ma famille.
Donc, j'ai de nouveau fait ma valise.
J'ai quitté la musique et j'ai déménagé aux États-Unis.
J'en avais assez.
Je voulais ne plus rien avoir à faire avec tout ceci.
Je n'allais sûrement pas être tuée pour quelque chose
qui n'était même pas mon rêve, mais le choix de mon père.
Alors...
Je me suis un peu perdue, effondrée en quelque sorte.
Mais j'ai décidé que ce que je voulais faire,
c'est de passer les années qu'il me reste à vivre
à aider les jeunes et essayer d'être là,
ne serait-ce qu'un peu, de toutes les façons possibles.
J'ai donc commencé à faire du bénévolat pour différentes organisations
travaillant avec les jeunes musulmans à l'intérieur de l'Europe.
Et, à ma grande surprise,
j'ai découvert qu'un si grand nombre de ces jeunes souffraient et peinaient.
Ils faisaient face à tant de problèmes avec leurs familles et communautés
qui semblaient plus concernées par leur honneur et leur réputation,
que par le bonheur et la vie de leurs propres enfants.
J'ai senti que peut-être, je n'étais pas si seule,
et que je n'étais pas si bizarre.
Peut-être existait-il beaucoup plus de gens comme moi.
Ce que la plupart des gens ne comprennent pas,
c'est qu'il y en a tant d'entre nous qui avons grandi en Europe,
qui ne sommes pas libres d'être nous-mêmes.
On ne nous permet pas d'être qui nous sommes.
Nous ne sommes pas libres de nous marier,
ou d'être en relation avec les gens que nous choisissons.
On ne peut pas choisir notre carrière.
C'est la norme chez les musulmans du cœur de l'Europe.
Même dans les sociétés les plus libres du monde, nous ne sommes pas libres.
Nos vies, nos rêves, nos futurs ne nous appartiennent pas.
Ils appartiennent à nos parents et leurs communautés.
J'ai découvert d'innombrables histoires de jeunes,
qui sont perdus pour nous tous,
qui sont invisibles pour nous tous,
mais qui souffrent, et qui souffrent seuls,
- des gamins que nous perdons dans des mariages forcés,
dans la violence et les abus basés sur l'honneur.
En fait, j'ai réalisé après plusieurs années avec ces jeunes,
que je ne pourrai pas continuer,
que je ne peux pas passer le reste de ma vie, effrayée, dissimulée,
et que j'allais devoir faire quelque chose.
Et j'ai aussi réalisé que mon silence, notre silence,
permet à de tels abus de continuer.
J'ai donc décidé de mettre à profit mes super-pouvoirs de mon enfance,
en essayant de faire comprendre aux gens de chaque côté de ces problèmes,
ce que c'est d'être une jeune personne coincée entre votre famille et votre pays.
Alors, j'ai commencé à faire des films, et à raconter ces histoires.
Je voulais aussi que les gens comprennent quelles sont les conséquences fatales
de ne pas prendre ces problèmes au sérieux.
Le premier film effectué fut sur Banaz.
C'était une jeune fille kurde, de 17 ans, à Londres.
Elle était obéissante, faisait tout ce que ses parents voulaient.
Elle essayait de tout faire bien.
Elle s'est mariée à quelqu'un, choisi par ses parents,
bien qu'il la frappait et la violait constamment.
Quand elle demandait l'aide de sa famille, ils disaient :
« Tu dois retourner et être une meilleure épouse »,
car ils ne voulaient pas avoir une fille divorcée sur le dos
car, bien sûr, cela apporterait le déshonneur sur la famille.
Elle était frappée si violemment que ses oreilles saignaient.
Quand, finalement, elle partit et trouva un jeune homme de son choix,
dont elle tomba amoureuse,
la communauté et la famille l'apprirent,
et elle disparut.
Elle fut découverte trois mois plus tard.
Elle avait été empaquetée dans une valise et enterrée sous la maison.
Elle avait été étranglée, et frappée à mort
par trois hommes, trois cousins, sur l'ordre de son père et de son oncle.
Le plus tragique dans l'histoire de Banaz,
c'est qu'elle s'était rendue à la police, en Angleterre,
cinq fois pour chercher de l'aide,
leur disant qu'elle allait être tuée par sa famille.
La police ne l'a pas crue donc, ils n'ont rien fait.
Le problème dans tout cela,
c'est que, non seulement beaucoup de nos gamins rencontrent ces problèmes
au sein de leurs familles et des communautés de leurs familles,
mais ils rencontrent aussi l'incompréhension et l'apathie
dans les pays où ils ont grandi.
Quand leurs propres familles les trahissent,
ils se tournent vers le reste d'entre nous.
Et quand nous ne comprenons pas,
nous les perdons...
Pendant que je faisais ce film, plusieurs personnes m'ont dit :
« Tu sais, Deeyah, c'est simplement leur culture.
C'est ce que ces gens font à leurs enfants,
et nous ne pouvons pas vraiment interférer. »
Je peux vous assurer qu'être assassiné n'est pas dans ma culture,
vous savez, et sans doute, celles qui me ressemblent,
les jeunes femmes venant des mêmes milieux que moi,
devraient être l'objet des mêmes droits et des mêmes protections
que n'importe qui dans notre pays, pourquoi ne serait-ce pas le cas ?
Donc, pour mon film suivant,
je voulais essayer de comprendre
pourquoi certains de nos jeunes musulmans, en Europe,
sont attirés par l'extrémisme et la violence.
Mais, avec ce sujet, j'ai aussi réalisé
que j'allais devoir faire face à ma pire peur :
les marrons à barbe !
Des hommes comme ceux qui m'ont harcelée la plus grande partie de ma vie,
des hommes dont j'ai eu peur la majeure partie de ma vie,
des hommes que j'ai aussi profondément détestés,
pendant de très nombreuses années !
J'ai donc passé les deux années suivantes à interviewer des terroristes condamnés,
des djihadistes et d'anciens extrémistes.
Ce que je savais déjà, ce qui était déjà très clair,
c'est que la religion, la politique, le bagage colonial de l'Europe,
et les échecs de la politique extérieure occidentale de ces dernières années,
faisaient tous partie du tableau.
Mais, ce qui m'intéressait plus,
c'était découvrir les raisons humaines et personnelles
pour lesquelles certains de nos jeunes sont réceptifs à de tels groupes.
Et ce qui m'a vraiment surprise, c'est que j'ai découvert des êtres blessés.
Au lieu des monstres que je souhaitais trouver
- que j'espérais trouver, honnêtement, car cela aurait été très gratifiant -
j'ai découvert des gens brisés.
Tout comme Banaz,
j'ai trouvé que ces jeunes hommes étaient déchirés
pour avoir essayé de combler le fossé
entre leurs familles et le pays dans lequel ils étaient nés.
J'ai appris, aussi, que les groupes extrémistes, terroristes,
profitent précisément de ces sentiments de nos jeunes,
et canalisent ceux-ci de façon cynique, vers la violence.
« Venez à nous ! » disent-ils,
« Rejetez les deux côtés, votre famille et votre pays,
parce qu'ils vous rejettent !
Pour votre famille, leur honneur est plus important que vous.
Et pour votre pays,
un vrai Norvégien, Britannique ou Français sera toujours un blanc, jamais vous ! »
Ils promettent aussi à nos jeunes, les choses dont ils ont soif :
importance, héroïsme, un sentiment d'appartenance et une motivation,
une communauté qui les aime et les accepte.
Ils donnent au faible le sentiment d'être fort.
Ceux qui étaient invisibles et silencieux sont enfin vus et entendus.
C'est cela qu'ils procurent à nos jeunes.
Pourquoi ces groupes procurent-ils cela à nos jeunes et pas nous ?
Le point est que je n'essaie pas de justifier
ou excuser quoi que ce soit de la violence.
Ce que j'essaie de dire, c'est que nous devons comprendre
pourquoi certains de nos jeunes sont attirés par ça.
En fait, je voudrais aussi vous montrer :
ce sont des photos d'enfance de certains de ces hommes dans le film.
Ce qui m'a vraiment frappée, c'est qu'un si grand nombre d'entre eux
- jamais je n'aurais pensé cela -
mais un si grand nombre d'entre eux ont des pères absents ou abusifs.
Et plusieurs de ces jeunes
finissent par trouver des images de père attentif et compatissant,
à l'intérieur de ces groupes extrémistes.
J'ai aussi découvert des hommes brutalisés par la violence raciste,
qui ont cessé de se sentir victimes en devenant eux-mêmes violents.
En fait, j'ai trouvé, avec horreur, quelque chose que j'ai bien reconnu.
J'ai trouvé le même sentiment que j'avais ressenti, à 17 ans, en fuyant la Norvège :
la même confusion, la même tristesse,
le même sentiment de trahison,
et de n'être à ma place nulle part,
le même sentiment d'être perdu, et déchiré entre deux cultures.
Cela dit, je n'ai pas choisi la destruction.
J'ai choisi de prendre la caméra au lieu du fusil.
Et je l'ai fait à cause de mes super-pouvoirs.
Je pouvais voir que comprendre est la réponse, plutôt que la violence :
voir les êtres humains,
avec toutes leurs vertus et toutes leurs faiblesses,
au lieu de continuer à caricaturer :
nous et eux, les méchants et les victimes.
J'ai finalement accepté le fait
que mes deux cultures n'avaient pas à être sur une trajectoire de collision,
mais, au contraire, sont devenues un espace où je trouve ma propre voix.
J'ai cessé de sentir comme si je devais choisir un camp,
mais cela m'a pris des années et des années.
Il y a tant de nos jeunes, aujourd'hui, aux prises avec ces mêmes problèmes...
Et ils luttent seuls.
Ce sont des écorchés vifs.
Et pour certains, la vision du monde de l'Islam radical
devient une infection qui suppure dans ces plaies ouvertes.
Un proverbe africain dit :
« Si les jeunes ne sont pas initiés au village,
ils le brûleront rien que pour ressentir sa chaleur. »
Je souhaiterais demander
aux parents musulmans et aux communautés musulmanes :
aimerez-vous et prendrez-vous soin de vos enfants
sans les forcer à répondre à vos attentes ?
Pouvez-vous les choisir à la place de votre honneur ?
Pouvez-vous comprendre pourquoi ils sont si en colère et exclus
quand vous placez votre honneur avant leur bonheur ?
Pouvez-vous essayer d'être un ami pour votre enfant,
afin qu'il vous fasse confiance
et désire partager avec vous ses expériences,
plutôt que d'avoir à chercher cela ailleurs ?
Et à nos jeunes gens tentés par l'extrémisme :
pouvez-vous réaliser que votre rage est alimentée par la douleur ?
Trouverez-vous la force de résister à ces vieux hommes cyniques
qui souhaitent utiliser votre sang pour leurs propres bénéfices ?
Pouvez-vous trouver une façon de vivre ?
Ne voyez-vous pas que la plus douce vengeance,
c'est que vous viviez une vie heureuse, pleine et libre ?
Une vie définie par vous et personne d'autre ?
Pourquoi ne voulez-vous que devenir un autre gamin musulman mort ?
Et pour le reste d'entre nous :
quand commencerons-nous à écouter nos jeunes ?
Comment pouvons-nous les soutenir en réorientant leur douleur
vers quelque chose de plus constructif ?
Ils pensent que nous ne les aimons pas, et nous moquons de ce qui leur arrive,
que nous ne les acceptons pas.
Pouvons-nous trouver un moyen pour qu'ils se sentent autrement ?
Que nous faut-il pour les voir et les remarquer,
avant qu'ils ne deviennent soit les victimes, ou les auteurs de violence ?
Pouvons-nous nous forcer à nous soucier d'eux et les considérer des nôtres ?
Et ne pas être en rage seulement
quand les victimes de violence nous ressemblent ?
Pouvons-nous trouver un moyen de rejeter la haine
et effacer les divisions entre nous ?
Nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre de nous laisser tomber, nous ou nos enfants,
même si, eux, nous ont laissé tomber.
Nous sommes tous ensemble là-dedans.
À long terme, vengeance et violence ne marcheront pas contre les extrémistes.
Les terroristes veulent que nous nous blottissions de peur dans nos maisons.
en fermant nos portes et nos cœurs.
Ils veulent que nous ouvrions plus de blessures dans nos sociétés,
pour pouvoir les utiliser et répandre leur infection plus largement.
Ils veulent que nous devenions comme eux :
intolérants, haineux et cruels.
Le lendemain des attaques de Paris,
un de mes amis a envoyé cette photo de sa fille.
C'est une fillette blanche avec une fillette arable.
Elles sont meilleures amies.
Cette image est la kryptonite des extrémistes.
Ces deux fillettes, avec leurs super-pouvoirs
montrent la voie à suivre
vers une société que nous devons construire ensemble,
une société qui intègre et soutient,
plutôt que de rejeter nos enfants.
Je vous remercie de m'avoir écoutée.
(Applaudissements)